welcome back well choosing a new year's
resolution is easy but sticking to it is
the hard part here to help us stay on
track is co-founder of everyday woman
elite ventura rosen hello khalid hi
jillian how are you good thank you so
much for being here and this is really
important to talk about because we all
do it we all set those resolutions and a
couple weeks into january we kind of
forget about it so let's talk about what
is your very first number one tip for
staying on track so i always start with
the mindset that's my thing so we're
going to switch you from new year's
resolutions to setting goals okay i like
that because that has a longer shelf
life of 12 months instead of just a few
weeks where a lot of us usually drop our
new year's resolutions so a little
easier to maintain it throughout the
year and something else that i think is
really important is having someone along
for the ride to keep you accountable
right yeah so just like going to the gym
when you know someone's meeting you
there or the personal trainer is meeting
you there you show up because you feel
bad so having an accountability partner
a friend or even a mentor could be a
fellow employee depending on what goals
if they're personal or if they're
related to your business or to your job
and once you have those things in place
where do you go from there well it's
really important to recognize that we
get very overwhelmed from setting a goal
so when you have a plan and break it up
into steps and now you focus on each
step to accomplish and more than
anything you've got to remember to kind
of celebrate with each step because now
you're a step closer to accomplishing
those new year's resolutions which is so
wonderful and more than anything let's
make sure we set up goals and new year's
resolutions that are attainable because
sometimes we come up with this idea
and it's oh wait i have 12 months to
accomplish that how can i do that so
when you set yourself up for success
it's so much easier yeah and having
those little celebrations along the way
just kind of keep you going and give you
that extra push and what happens if say
you fall off for a little bit how do you
recommend people just get back on and
keep moving forward one of the things we
do is we're really hard on ourselves and
when we're hard on ourselves we don't go
back to accomplishing the goal step back
look at the little steps that you need
to take to accomplish that goal and just
focus on maybe just doing one of those
things this week i really love that and
i'm all about writing things down
because i think that makes it really
real and makes you follow through with
it so all these tips are just so helpful
thank you so much for breaking it down i
have to start thinking about this
something that is actually attainable
for the new year yes
glee thank you so much for being here
you always have the best